okay so let me find our document
um
are we recording
you are
okay
so
um it's it's uh 931 uh as chair of
division three of the house finance
committee i find that due to the stated
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covet 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04 has extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's order however in accordance
with the emergency order i'm confirming
that
we have are providing the public with
access by telephone and by by zoom
we are using the committee is using zoom
for this
meeting all members of the committee and
staff and state agencies with agenda
items
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously watch and or
listen to the meeting on zoom or phone
uh following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar
starting at house calendar eight running
in every calendar through 15.
the public
has been noticed that they can access
this meeting
by the instructions that are found in
the house calendar to include by uh
calling in
uh if people are not able to access this
meeting we ask that you email us at lba
underscore
fiscal
if you
let us know that you're having a problem
the public is having a problem then we
will adjourn and reschedule our our
meeting
um
please note that any votes taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
and let's start the meeting with taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting it's required by
the right to know law so mr clerk are
you ready to take a role
representative earth
president
i'm alone in my home office
representative weiler i'm here in
concord in my office
representative bean
i'm home in guildford my wife is here
she's doing some things in the other
room
remembering walner
i'm in my home in concord and my husband
is in the other room
come back to her representative rogers
um katherine rogers i'm in concord in my
apartment um no one's here except my dog
romeo
representative edwards
representative edwards in my home office
in auburn i have family in the house but
mr president except for representative
nordgren i'm sure she'll show up in a
little bit she's here
[Music]
yes
so
uh good morning everyone
um
so my
calendar for today
uh listed uh several
sections of a house bill 2 that i i
wanted us to discuss and
get a feel for if we're ready to pass it
or if we we have issues with it
specifically uh we're going to talk
about sections 21
and 28
then i've asked uh mr ripple to prepare
to give us sort of a little
tutorial on the history of of uses of
lapses
because i've i've heard about it three
or four times and i i think i have a
general idea but i i need to hear it
another time to be more clear on it
um
we
uh
if we have time i'd like to continue
having us talk about hb2 items
uh we heard from the veterans home uh i
believe it was sections
107 108
and we can we can just introduce those
and and talk about them and see if uh
what the general sense of the committee
is relative to them
um
and then i i would like us
to uh take sort of a focused
re-dive around
five accounts
those five accounts are
medicaid
chip
tanf
mmis and the county cap
when we're talking about the county cap
i want us to take a look
at a word document that the governor's
office shared with us yesterday evening
showing what they project to be coming
from the federal government and how it's
going to be distributed in a way that
bypasses the state to work completely
and goes uh straight to counties uh
cities and municipalities so we should
be we should have such a situational
awareness of of that money as we take a
look at the county cap
um so so that's
that's what i think our agenda is for
today uh one of our members uh has a
medical appointment at three and needs
to leave before that to get there
so i'm i'm kind of hoping to be done
uh around two ish 2 15 or so
um
and then uh
that so that's kind of my plan
representative nordgren
oh yes uh could we please have our lunch
break at 12 15 to 1 o'clock
let's try for that i i don't see why we
couldn't
okay thank you
are there any other
questions or comments about what we're
why we're gathered here today
i
i do want to do one more update um and
i'll
i'll bring you in mr uh representative
weiler go ahead
what do you
what would you like to answer
um
we were having that eight o'clock
meeting with the governor this morning
on this money that's coming in
from this
recovery act and it appears that it will
all come through the state
and in some cases uh some of the small
towns and so on
will just be kind of pulling it down
because that way they they avoid the
auditing and the accounting that the
state would then have to do so
it's liable to come through the state
thank you
uh so i i have a question for you on
that is that just an administrative uh
through though is it do we have the
authority as a state to change um dollar
amounts for any designated counties or
designated municipalities
or is it just administratively passed
through us administratively passed
through but of course the other warning
is it's going to be a while before it's
all there and it won't all come right
away and you might get 50 of it at a
time and it might
go to the next year so
don't get excited and spend it all at
once kind of thing
okay
thank you for that and we'll we'll we'll
come back to it and have a deeper talk
uh representative wallner do you did you
i think that i think uh
chairman weiler just answered my
question i guess
my question was when do we think we're
going to
receive this uh money and it sounds like
it's sort of up in the air
yeah it may not be till the fall
okay
and uh robert weiler do you know and i
should i certainly could
take a look at this myself but do you
know if there's going to be
like in that first um
cares act
there were timelines around when the
money had to be spent
is that
you know if that's going to be if if
counties and towns and are going to have
to expend the money by a certain date
there was uh no information on that yet
they're still waiting they think some of
it may come through the treasury the
treasury may be the ones making the
rules so that's going to be a while
okay thank you
so just an update on on on that i i
received uh
naomi and i received our 2 800 overnight
and it was a nice little
christmas present this morning
so
uh so some of the money's flowing
through the system already
uh
mr ripple did you did you mean to say
something i
i'm all set
um
all right so
to to to close out a conversation point
that we had yesterday around whether or
not we would post
um our working document uh i i've i've
with mr ripple's help and uh mr
input
i've decided that we should just go
ahead and post our working document
i would like every
page
clearly marked
subject of frequent changes
and our final
is due
24 march
because i i'm still concerned that
posting a working document that changes
every few minutes
is not good communication with the
public it's going to be more confusing
so
i i just want that document when it's
shared on the website to be properly
disclaimed because
it will immediately frighten people who
think that uh
who are concerned that their accounts
will be
uh diminished and um and that that is
not the right way to view it
so but
we can't control how people will view
things
um with that
i
think we're ready to talk about
section
21.
do you want to can are you ready to
share it mr ripple can you put it up so
thank you
okay so um i i think you all have looked
at this a number of times this this is
about um allowing authority
uh for
unfunded positions to be funded
based on the availability of money
and i think
uh as i remember our discussion around
this
representative weiler
you had some thoughts on it and
and i i i'd like to just verify that if
if you have an amendment or whether you
would like it this section dropped
i'd like to know what you're thinking so
that mr ripple can work on it
okay
this is similar to what we did in the
previous budget
but what we did was we said here's your
limit
and i think we limited the number of
employees as well
and if they wanted if they had a couple
of retirements or people resigning then
that left gaps that they could fill with
some positions that were unfunded at
that moment but approved so
this wouldn't change it that much
according to what we put in the budget
for positions so
if we accepted this we'd still have
control by how much
money we put in class 10
and so
it
it's kind of like what we did before
it's a little more generous but
we could probably stand it i don't know
okay so
because i studied computer science i got
to be really precise on this i'm sorry
what i what i think i just heard you say
is
you you have no
recommended changes to section 21 that
you would accept that word for word
comma for comma
correct
is there is there any other
committee
i'm not seeing any um
for the public
the way i would like to do this is to
get through all of the sections that we
plan on talking today
about today
if you if you want to speak on any of
these sections we'll entertain questions
about what we've discussed
uh before uh we take any votes so
um
did you have a question representative
you went for your screen
no
no i'm i'm i'm fine with this section
okay thank you
go ahead represent walter it sounds like
you do have something you might want
well no i just wondered are we going to
vote on these as we go along or
i i think uh if uh i'm going to try
something different i'm going to try a
block vote at the end if we have
you know what seems to be strong
agreement on all of them
so like for example the one we just
talked about
i might couple it with two or three
other ones if we if nobody's voicing any
concerns about them
so i'm trying to figure out ways
to to have our votes and and be a little
quicker about about it
um
okay
section 23.
uh this is uh
about
allowing
the the
the colas
to increase eligibility levels
so that
uh people don't
fall out of eligibility due to a cost of
living adjustment
so um i think as i remember my notes on
this
this this is something that may actually
be required by federal law for us to
continue receiving some federal funds
is does anyone have any further
con and my conclusion is i'm i think i'm
fine with section 23.
but i want to hear from anyone who may
have uh other information or other
viewpoints
i think i'd ask uh mr ripple if this is
in there on a routine basis i think it
is
it is it's definitely in the current
2021 trailer bill um
i have to go back further than that but
i think it's been in for the past
several bills yes yeah
out of curiosity oh i see karen rounds
on there too
at some point we might just pull her in
as a panelist um okay
do you want me to do that now
i think it's fine
i think i think we may end up with a
now section 24 county reimbursement
this is this is a lot on the county cap
area this i think we need to talk about
this in conjunction
with
um
the federal money that's coming down
so uh i would i would like to defer 24 a
little bit
so that we can knock out some of these
other sections that may be uh
more approachable
so
so we're going to come back to 24
but let's let's for a moment go to
now
my notes on section 25
uh
had had me a little bit confused what i
think section 25 the effect of 25 is
is if we ex accept
the uh amendment
from 2023
22 from 2021 to 2023
that that we will
continue a trend that started in around
and and that this in effect saves the
state some money
and if we decided to quit doing this we
would have to find some money to put
into one of our activity codes i think
that's the background on this does
anyone have
uh any comments if the committee doesn't
have any comments this is one i'd like
to just hear from uh either mr ripple or
ms rounds
on to to make sure that uh
we're clear on the
effect of this
uh before we do that
representative wallner do you want to
let this round speak first and then and
then you ask okay that's what that's
what i was that's what i was going to
ask you to do bring up karen to talk
about this section
thank you
yes ma'am um ms rounds
good morning so i'm just looking at the
notes that uh john williams provided to
me so
um i do know that he did provide me some
language um
putting off the repeal since 2011
so
he did provide me with language to
repeal the repeal so this would no
longer need to be in every trailer bill
um if that's something the committee's
and i'm just hold on just one second i
just want to make sure that i say this
correctly
yeah so the
hb 191 which was the original law for
this apparently um
allowed cmhcs to prioritize delivery of
services based on an individual's
clinical needs essentially allowing for
a wait list
that has not been needed and there's not
been a wait list so
we continue to hold off on this
on this because of that that it's been
properly funded and there's not been an
issue so i i think it's fine to leave it
the way it is but if we want to stop
putting in hb2 year after year it's been
10 years and we've kept it the same we
can
do something to eliminate it completely
all right representative i i have a
question for you on there but i i see mr
or excuse me representative weiler's
hand is up and i know representative may
have a question
representative weiler thank you mr
chairman so
if we did
have uh more people coming becoming
eligible than we had funds for we'd
still have to go to a waiting list so
maybe we shouldn't eliminate um this if
um
quick quick question
yes all right do you mind if we bring
katya over
she uh katy is the director for
behavioral health she can probably give
you a more in-depth explanation than i
can
okay this is bigger than behavioral
health though isn't it this is the whole
medicaid program isn't it
um it is but conti is familiar with the
behavioral health pieces of the medicaid
performance fox speaks i i think we got
to put a couple more things out on the
table uh representative weiler your hand
is still up okay representative did you
have something
no but i would like to hear from miss
fox for sure about this one okay so the
idea of uh
of having a wait list
um it can be called different sorts of
things but oregon implemented
a
system several many many years ago it
could well over a decade
where
um they
racked and stacked
all of the drgs
uh that medicaid was paying for from the
most
clinically useful to the least
clinically effective
and so if they ever ran into a shortage
of money
they would use that list to start
prioritizing
which clinical procedures they would
continue to pay for
and which ones would have to be
weighed out
until there was more money available in
the state
and although i don't like that system
i can see the potential for needing to
have a system such as that
and so so what i would like to know is
if we if we leave this language in here
does this leave us with the authority to
create
effectively
a waiting list if if we if we needed to
do that in a worse case
so
representative weiler your hand is up
yes thank you mr chair
uh you run into the complication of you
put money aside in this fund
and now you ran short of it in that fund
and you have to transfer money from one
fund to another you got to go to fiscal
some delays um
and
you know and then people that are
looking at the money and the fund you
took it from why you're taking it out of
our fund you know
it's not as easy as it looks because
it's all in separate funds plus the
percentages in each fund
between federal and
agency and
general funds
could be different in each case so
it's
not as simple as it looks
to adopt that system
thank you
thank you sir uh
so if representative or representative
if ms fox is
ready to speak to us i'd love to hear
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record i'm katya foxx
i'm the director of the division for
behavioral health for the department and
what um this language is so confusing
and every single time it comes up we
have to go back and do the history on it
um if you think about the time period
when it was put in it was when we were
struggling with our budget and had uh
revenue issues as well so this was put
in to protect the community mental
health centers essentially so that they
were not stuck on
having to
provide services when the state was not
providing enough funding and so this
allowed them to
create the so-called waitlists
for services
and as
karen round said
this has never had to happen but it was
a safety net so it's really a safety net
for the centers
because of the continuous
inclusion of this in
the trailer bill
we're fine with it going away and we're
also fine with it staying
but that really is is the point of it is
to protect the community mental health
centers
um so they don't have to continue
services when they don't have the means
to um to pay for their staff and and for
the services
right
so
so if if we ever got into a worst-case
scenario and the state didn't have money
wouldn't it be reasonable to say that
the providers shouldn't be forced to
provide services if they're not going to
ms fox
thank you uh for
so are
are there any other
comments from the committee
i is there a hand up in the audience
there uh mr ripple there is could i
actually make one comment if you don't
sure
um i think he would want to get a good
look at the department's language before
deciding what it would do because as i
understand
i think if it repeals the repeal
that would have the effect of leaving
the existing language in place and the
existing language
continues to make
mental health services subject to
available appropriations so if you're
repealing the repeal
you would be making that limitation
permanent
rather than extending it for another two
years
that's confusing i'm sorry
no no
you
you just ran into headspace limitations
on my part is all uh that's
um
okay so so so the bottom line
is
i don't want to leave the possibility
that if the state runs out of money
that we would be compelling providers to
so if that was the position we wanted to
end up with
do we accept this language as it is and
kick the can down to 2023
or do we go with the williams language
to repeal the repeal
i mean they can't both do the same thing
i believe they they both do the same
thing this this
does it for two years and my
understanding of the hhs language is it
would do it permanently
is mr williams in the audience with us
today
he's more than welcome
or or if ms rounds from her notes with
mr williams can speak to that that
that that
leaving the existing language and using
the williams language
gets us to the same place it gets us to
the point where the state can't compel
providers to provide services
that is my understanding and i i believe
that um i i just sent kevin the email
with the language from mr williams and i
think he had
ols maybe look at it or as well so i
know it would go through them again but
um i do believe that that's what it does
so i think based on that we know um
we know enough and i see mr scabie with
his hands up but i think what what we
know
is that
we can't vote on this today we we need
to share
mr williams language with the committee
members and have everyone think about
which way they want to go
if we end up in the same spot
by either
sticking with hb2 as is
or by using mr williams language i would
prefer the solution
that is more long term so that we get
out of this kick in the can mode but but
we need to all individually look at this
and think about it
are there any questions about the
committee i'd like to i'd like to close
out
discussion on
which one are we on we're on section 25
pending uh a further discussion after we
i'm not i'm not seeing any objections
um
mr skibby took your hand down i was just
about to call you if you if you think
you have something um
relevant to to the particular decision
we're trying to make right now uh we we
thank you mr chair um mike skibby from
the disability rights center um
i think
it's important to recognize that the the
law before the fiscal crisis of 2011
was
and i'll read it to you because it's
right in the statute books
admission to the
mental health services
system the state's mental health
services system which includes the
mental health centers but it also
includes other components of the state's
mental health system
shall not be denied
um based on inability to pay so
basically before 2011 there was a
commitment by the state to care for
poor people who are mentally ill
and in 2011 the mental health center
said
we are concerned about that continuing
in statute under the current
crisis circumstances so we would like to
have the authority to create a wait list
for mental health services it's not a
broad
medicaid provision it's completely
focused on poor people with mental
health problems
and so
a temporary
change to the statute was adopted by the
legislature and it was to expire in two
years
so that has been repeatedly
you know the can has been repeatedly
been kicked down the road by saying okay
it's not gonna expire this time it'll
expire two years from now and that's
happened um several times and here we
are again with kicking the can down the
road
um
so
i guess the question is
is there some reason that we should
continue to operate as though we are
under a fiscal crisis like we were in
2011. it seems to me that there is a
theoretical possibility that we're going
to run out of money for mental health
services but i really doubt that
you're going to run out of money for
for admitting people to the new
hampshire hospital who are poor for
example
and it seems to me that
it makes sense to remove this provision
completely and return to the
pre-existing
i would say you know morally sound
commitment by the state to care for the
for poor people who are extremely
mentally ill
um
i would like to get a distinction here
though
it is as it was described prior to your
testimony
this was about whether or not the state
had money to pay
the provider
i i don't i don't i i think pretty much
everyone has accepted
that
our health the american health system
accepts every poor patient
regardless of their ability to pay
but but this this is this reads a little
different to me if it's really that the
state is no longer in a position to
reimburse the provider
and so
uh so i i see that um
mr ripple has highlighted what he
believes to be the critical part of the
the law um but would you just address
that or
are we talking about
which of these two things are we talking
about the state's inability to pay or
well the language refers to the state
mental health services system
which is composed of the community
services that are administered by the
state and the institutional services
that are administered by the state so
the community services are largely but
not solely
administered by the community mental
health system the community mental
health centers
so the language is not
is is not only focused on
community services but i agree it's
largely because of their concerns that
it was adopted so the highlighted
language is the current law which
expires in july of this year
but what was the prior law and what will
become law
on july 1
is that eligibility shall not be denied
based on a number of things including
inability to pay
period paragraph not paragraph but not
the but without
the additional authority to create a
wait list
so
it's the question that you ought to be
asking yourself is is there some reason
that we should walk away permanently
from that commitment to poor people
or should we continue to make it a
temporary walking away from that you
know unqualified commitment or should we
or should we
you know just put put it off
for another two years so
um i think that i i don't think that
there's any reason to think that we are
still in the emergency situation we were
in in
2011 and that there ought to be some
presumption that we returned to the
commitment that was made you know many
years ago
um
and there's really no reason um you know
to think that that commitment is not
something that that we can follow
through on
yeah okay so i do appreciate your
testimony and and i think you've uh
helped ratify the decision to postpone a
further discussion and a vote on this
because we need to see mr williams
language
and um i you know i i need to get into
this
this paragraph that mr ripple is
highlighting for us
um
and i just i just would say that i i
as i'm reading this i'm going to try to
be making the distinction between
providing emergency services to the
indigent
which is which has
become an american value of our health
system
and
whether or not the state can compel
private individuals to provide services
that the state knows it's unable to pay
for
that second category
gets into a bit of an enslavement issue
if you compel people without
reimbursement to do work so
so i i do think these are different
issues and there's a philosophical
nuance in there
and i don't know which side of that uh
divide we're on until i
i i re-read all this so
um
well i think i do think
i do think that you can
i don't i don't i don't want to debate
if you if you if you have some more
uh written input for us as we as we
review this overnight
uh
it'd be great we'd i'd be happy to have
us review it but but i would like to
continue because we have we do have a
um thank you
thank you sir
uh unless you have something that you
think is really relevant right now i
don't want to i don't want to shut you
down
oh my i think i removed his ability to
all i was going to say is that i think
you can
you can modify the statute so that you
relieve community mental health programs
of being
um required to provide services without
payment without without you know walking
away from the commitment to poor people
and i'll i'll send you some suggested
language
thank you sir appreciate it
um
all right so uh
i don't want to unilaterally make that
decision but i'm i'm prepared to
postpone further discussion on 25 until
tomorrow or the day after if anyone
disagrees uh you know on the committee
let me know
uh otherwise i think we're ready to take
okay
so
miss rounds i'm going to invite you in
here in just a moment but as i
understand what section 28 does
is it it
it allows for
there to be a fund
that
people can donate to
and that that fund would then be
available to help pay for emergency
services
am i close or how far off am i no you're
pretty close um
your volume is really low for some
reason that's weird let me try is that
any better
that's much better okay all right i will
stay like this um kevin could you bring
over rebecca ross just in case i forget
to say something she can she can add um
she's the legislative liaison for dcyf
um
so actually section 28 and section 29 go
together um so i know you don't have 29
slated until tomorrow but i'm just going
to talk about them
together because they're they're really
for the same purpose
28 adds the fund to
um the revolving account part of the
statute and establishes the revolving
account and 29 talks about what the
purpose of it is
so to talk about the purpose and basic
terms
so dcyf
has times when there is an emergency
type situation that they need to resolve
something immediately so that a child
can
stay in their home with their parents or
so that a foster family is fully
prepared in that moment to take a child
so it could mean
purchasing a crib or a car seat
or
formula or something like that
and it's literally something that needs
to happen
right now right so uh so this is
something that currently happens in dcyf
there's about
thousand dollars a year in general funds
budgeted in the dcyf budget
for this purpose
um
so about a year ago
uh i would say it was about a year ago a
year and a half ago i became more aware
of this process and what i wanted to do
is to make it um
[Music]
a little bit more
of a
uh
to put more controls on it that's what
i'm trying to say to put more controls
on it by establishing this account for
this to happen in and for it to only
happen in this account um and so that is
the purpose of setting this up the other
thing as we were working on this
language with john williams and rebecca
ross
and and director ribsum
is one thing that i learned is that
there are times that people call dcyf
and want to make a donation and we could
certainly take a donation to the
department but it doesn't necessarily go
it
it's a little bit harder to make it for
a specific purpose this account now
allows us to have a very specific
purpose that we can say if you would
like to make a donation to the
department we have this fund that we use
to um
to help families with you know emergent
needs and that's what your donation
would go to and so hoping therefore in
the longer run that we start to offset
those general funds that we're currently
using for those emergent needs um
rebecca is there anything i missed
no i think that's that's an accurate
summary
so so thank you i
okay
so this was written by the department
and in this language from line 8
to line 17 in section 29
i i
i think what you're letting us know is
that this has not gone to a policy
committee anywhere
is that true
correct yes this is this is the
language the language that establishes
it it's pretty common to have revolving
accounts established in hb2
yeah well so that my next several
questions shouldn't be implied to be
against the bill or anything i i just
want to make sure i
i ask some process questions sure okay
so so i i have a bias in favor of policy
committees reviewing
new things
because it's i i have seen many times
i've read something before committee
hearings
where i thought i understood exactly
every issue
and somebody would come in
to the hearing and they would point out
a comma or they would point out a word
and and it's something i didn't even see
that needed to be changed or amended and
so
so without having
eyes
on this i'm i'm kind i'm a little
concerned that we're
using a potentially faulty process
that that's just that's just commentary
about process
uh on line 14 for example where it says
the funds may be comprised of public
funds
gifts grants donations
the idea of using this for gifts grants
and donations
seems to be in line with the intent of
this fund
but then when you insert the term public
funds
what then distinguishes this account
from any other account that we would
use for or put general funds into
so the reason that i wanted to so it
it offers more transparency it creates a
revolving account that gets reported out
annually
there's an annual report that has to be
filed with revolving funds it also
allows us to segregate this um as a
separate fund uh so it really is about
more transparency and more control over
this part of the program
yes ma'am i i don't believe you answered
my question though okay
if if we keep the term public funds on
line 14
doesn't this become
really
another
line of expense that we would we could
put gen or line of revenue that that
would be open to having general funds
put into it
yes
yes we are already using general funds
for this purpose
okay for this purpose but not for this
fund because this fund doesn't exist
correct
correct so we would move the general
funds that we already use for this
could the fiscal committee do that if
the words public funds were stricken
from line 14
yes because it also says or any other
representative wallner your hand is up
yes karen would we start to see in the
budget
a line where it would be i labeled i
guess emergency funds
we start to see that line in the budget
where now
we don't see it
correct correct and right now it's just
within
another class line of 2958 this would we
would either put it in its own separate
accounting unit or put it in its own
class line in 2958
and just to follow up so it would
possibly be the general funds that are
showing up someplace else that we really
don't
know exactly what they're
that they're in there so those would be
there and then
if
you did receive
donations from
organizations or individuals who wanted
to be sure to help um
[Music]
children in an emergency situation those
would go there so they would be the
public would be able to see that those
funds were going to that emergency fund
and not just dump into the regular
budget correct and
those
this account
it's established as a revolving account
so it would be
non-lapsed and continuously appropriated
so those donations that were that would
be made to this fund could not be moved
for any other purpose and would not be
lapsed they they would be there until
they were spent
thank you
thank you um i think
bottom line is this is a transparency
transparency
so that the public has knowledge of
where the money's come from and where
it's gone this is something we would be
wise to
thank you for that
i'm generally
thinking i'm agreeing with you
and now i'm down deep into the weeds um
so so let me say this back to you miss
your hand is still up represent waller
okay so
so i'm i just want to make sure i'm
getting this clear if we on line 14 if
we struck the
term public funds from it
that would have the effect
of taking it out of our normal two-year
budgeting process we wouldn't be
putting money into it on our two-year
budgeting process
but if for some reason there was a money
available that the department wanted to
transfer general funds into this account
they would still have a mechanism for
doing that by going to the joint fiscal
committee
and
under the the part of this that says
that the it can accept any other source
of funds
the joint legislative fiscal committee
would would have the authority to move
general funds into this new fund is
is that correct i don't i don't think
that removing public funds would would
keep it from being in the two-year
budget cycle i think it's still
we have other revolving funds some that
have no general funds we still put it in
the two-year budget cycle and budget
funds in it so i don't and i don't think
it would restrict us from budgeting
i mean i would defer to kevin a little
bit but i i don't think it would
no i i agree with that i think as long
as it says any other source of funds
that could include
funds or any other appropriation that
but it would be the
you would see it as a separate class
line or a separate accounting unit so
you would see if we were we were
budgeting funds into this account it
wouldn't be
okay so so i so given that i i like the
general idea uh why am i asking these
kinds of questions it's because
every time we open up a revolving
account we're essentially
obligating
future legislatures because once the
money gets in there
future legislatures aren't going to
reach into this revolving fund and pull
money out and so
we're
we're sort of put inserting ourselves
into this category of
of permanency
that i don't think is appropriate for
one legislature to
find another
so
i'm i'm just i'm just a little concerned
about the impact of this
um
so
i i'd like to
go ahead uh representative morgan
no i just want to clarify this is
setting up a process
a public process
for money that
would otherwise probably be hidden
from everyone knowing what was coming
and going is this setting up a
yes ma'am and i love that part of it and
if and if this only said gifts grants or
donations
i i'd already be ready to move on it's
it's it's the idea that we could put
general money general funds money into
this and that it would have this sort of
multi
biennium budget effect that is the thing
that i'm trying to wrap my head around
because i don't think one legislature
should should should bind the decisions
of
coming legislatures but so um
representative erf if you had your hand
up and then represented walnut will come
to you
i just have a quick question for karen
how would we see
general funds
being allocated to a revolving fund i
just don't recall
running into that in the budget process
sure it would be
either in its own accounting unit or
in its own class line
and the revenue source is typically
revolving funds at the bottom so like
the vaccine fund i think says revolving
funds if i remember correctly
there's a couple um
that have the revenue sources revolving
funds
oh
okay
so the red the vaccines says this is
5177. it says funding revolving funds
and then it as general funds zero so
that oh that would always show up the
general fund's zeroed we're giving an
indication that general funds could go
into that account
right but the um if there are not any
budgeted there's not any budgeting okay
thank you
representative
sorry i got sidetracked i had somebody
else ask me a question here in the house
so i got sidetracked but karen we're
already we're already appropriating
money for this purpose isn't that
correct that's correct
we are and so i
this was a project of mine to try to
make it more transparent and track it
better
okay we just don't we just don't see it
correct
so
okay it's about 50 000 a year it's not a
significant amount of money
um but it's just something that given
the type of expenditure it's something
that it's good to have good controls
over
right thank you very much
and so in your view it's it it
although the term public funds is
redundant because we say any other
source of funds
it it
would be your position that we should
keep the phrase public funds in there
i i mean i i don't
i don't think it matters if you leave it
or take it out
as long as it says any other source of
funds
any other questions
about section 29 we we did we did bring
it forward from tomorrow
um but are there any other questions
i'm not i'm not seeing any from the
committee so
what
what i'm thinking we can do and and uh
mr ripple if if you've got a
a pencil to write some of this down
i i think i think i'd like to
have us
entertain and debate a motion
on
having the committee accept
sections
28 and 29.
okay
in other words
i think we need to
talk more today about the county
reimbursement the section 24.
and i think on section 25 we said we
wanted to see
uh mr williams language and and i
personally want to go read the
rsa
section more closely
so
i would like to entertain a motion mr
vice chair on
whether or not uh the committee approves
the four sections i just listed uh would
you read them and back again mr ripple
those four yep they're sections 21 23 28
okay so just so i'm clear you weren't in
the previous conversation putting those
off for another day you wanted to make
the motion now is that correct
these there are there we've gone over
six sections four of them i think
it feels like we're ready to vote on two
of them were deferring okay so
i'd like to move that we
support item number 23 and hb2 keeping
it in the
in hb2 as written
i'm sorry sorry the wrong number but
going backwards
same thing with number 21 in hb2
and the same thing with numbers 28 and
uh representative seconds
is there any discussion on the motion
which again is we're we're about to vote
on whether or not we accept
sections uh say them again mr ripple
because i don't want to screw it up
so is there any discussion on whether or
not we accept
i'm not seeing any
so mr clerk are you ready to take a roll
all right on the motion
if you're in favor you'll say yes if i
oppose no
representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes
representative
all walner yes
okay
representative nordgren
yes
president of rogers
representative edwards
yes
thank you
um
so
we want to take a break at 12 15 so we
still have uh plenty of time um
let's let's improvise a little bit and
drop down to section 106 please
can you can you do that on your screen
mr ripple
what what page on you're on page 51
yeah i was looking at the pdf
number
okay
so
um
these are three hb2 line items
from the veterans home
these
sound
like they've all been in previous hb2s
in that these in combination with with
one another
give the commandant flexibility to
use personnel money and personnel slots
uh to
do what she needs to do to get people
there at the bedside whether it's via
contracts or per diems or
or whatever
so um
so i'm because we're we're sort of
accelerating this and these are not on
the schedule
i did want to just introduce them and
have us
take a look at it and and for you more
experienced people
you've probably seen this language
before
so so mr ripple would you
can you confirm
i am putting you on the spike but can
you confirm that these three sections
have been in previous hb2s as written
i'm not sure that the veterans home has
had section 106 before the unfunded
positions they have had 107. sorry i
just lost it the transfer among accounts
and classes
i would just comment here that they also
have sections 108 through 110 which are
duplicative of language elsewhere
either in house bill 1 or in section
106.
what i mean by that is
we go down to section 109
you can see on line 8
it refers to a waiver from rsa 917 a
limitations
if you go back up to section 107
like
section 1010 refers to a waiver from
rsa917c
that can be found on line 35.
so i think if you were to accept section
107 it's in its entirety
you could remove sections 109 and 110
and also
section 108 here on line one per diem
payments this reads the same as the
class note
that is in house bill 1 that the
veterans home talked about the other day
so i think you could remove that as well
or we could move remove the class node
yep
either way
so
so as as the new guy
i think i'd rather remove the class
nodes because hb2
is more visible
to the public and therefore
we would have a more transparent policy
if it was an hb2 and removed from the
class nodes
is that correct or wrong
well well i'm not sure which is more
transparent they both have the force of
law so either one would work
but for transparency where the public
can readily look at it and know what
we're doing
which one is more
transparent to the public
well i'm not sure which bill the public
is more is more likely to look at
so i don't really know the answer to
that
representative walner you had your hand
up and then representative weiler
i wondered i wondered how we um ended up
in a situation where
it was in both documents um
there must have been a reason for it at
the time
the reason why it was in both documents
do you know kevin
well
i remember seeing this when we were
going through the veterans homeland
earlier this week or
maybe it was last week but anyway when
we were going through the veterans home
i remember seeing this on their line and
i thought
that that's that's sort of interesting
because it's really sort of helpful
because it pertained to that line in the
budget
and it was kind of helped you'll see it
right there
if i didn't know to go looking and how
if it wasn't there and i didn't know to
go looking in house bill 2
i probably
wouldn't have ever known it was in house
bill 2.
so it seems like there's some benefit to
having it in house bill 1.
i'm
open to
hearing other
thoughts about it and i didn't know
whether the commandant maybe had a
preference
so so i'm open to learning from you so
what i think i just took away from your
comment representative walner is is that
you you you don't think it really should
be in both places and if we were to
choose one place you would want it in
the organizational notes
yes i think so
representative weiler do you have a
question sir or comment
i was going to say the same thing that
representative walnut just said if
you're talking about transparency and
someone's looking up a budget they'd
look up
you know the veterans home they wouldn't
look in
they wouldn't even imagine it being in
hb2 so if you're looking up something
about the veterans home you go to the
budget first and then you see the the
line note and that's that's far more
transparent than as she said you
wouldn't normally go looking in hb2
representative walter your hand is still
up or is it
all right
so
um
is does the veterans home
send a legislative liaison do they have
anyone actually
to hear us and to take comments
i suspect they don't and i see no hands
so
uh i would like
to add
uh discussion and decisions around 106
to what was the last one you said 110
110 yes
i would like to add those to
our agenda for
friday
and
and if we could if we could get an email
uh
to to uh the commandant
to let her know that we want some more
input on this and that we're thinking
about
removing redundancy in a couple of
different ways removing
one
section that's referring to another
section of hb2 and then
removing some hb2 language it's already
in an organizational node so so i
i think we could just clean up this area
and maybe they wouldn't lose anything um
10106 though is
is a new concept is what i'm also
hearing
so uh representative irf do you have a
comment
just a quick question for kevin what
page number is that in the pdf where the
class note is is it
those are the two that i see
class notes on
those would be the two the only two
class no i don't have the document up in
front of me but those are the only two
class notes that they have and i believe
they read the same for both accounting
units
okay and what does that one tied to back
in hp2 which number and hp 2
the section number yes
uh sections
section 108.
okay um
representative weiler i'm gonna i'm
gonna put you on the spot a little bit
sir uh you can defer if you if you want
uh more time but
as you read section 106
lines 21 through 24
how how do you react to that sir
similar to what we've done with hhs if
you know it allows you some flexibility
if you uh
if you have someone leaving and you have
positions you've got to fill then
you would be able to do that
[Music]
you know as long as you don't exceed
so i'm interpreting that to mean you you
have no
um
no reason no problems i have no problem
okay
um
so let's see if we can get it off the
there any 107 needs to be resolved with
108 i believe you said mr ripple
107 isn't in conflict with 108 but it
includes some language that's also
included in 109.
consider that redundancy conflict just
because
i i i think i think we should just defer
all
five of these 106 to 110
uh for consideration on friday and
um i i don't think anyone has a problem
with 106 but but in terms of uh
redundancy i think we
just
for the good of the state may want to
clean that up
um
[Music]
all right
does anyone disagree with that approach
nope
all right no disagreement
okay so uh mr ripple
are are you ready to to
to give us another
uh bite at the apple a tutorial on
the uses of lapses in our final prod
product that that's good that's due on
the 24th the uses of lapses uh and kind
of the history of how lapses get used as
part of the budgeting process
sure i can give you a brief history um i
think as far as what division three has
to produce by the 24th
you don't necessarily have to be
concerned with the lapse because we
won't identify a department's specific
lapse number
we'll only identify a statewide lapse
number on our surplus statement
and i can go down and find that
in our surplus statement for the current
in just a moment but as far as
the lapse is concerned
budgeting for relapse really goes back
to
1980s i think prior to that the state
didn't do it
and i think to provide some historical
perspective frankly the way it came
about was
the legislature needed to find a way to
balance its budget
in one of those sessions in the 80s and
somebody came up with the idea to say
well hey
state agencies don't spend every dime of
their appropriation
let's assume that agencies will last 10
million 20 million whatever of the
amount they've given them
and that allows us to balance the budget
and so
for that reason every budget since has
included a statewide general fund lapse
figure
the percentage of that that lapse amount
varies it's been between two percent
four percent of general fund
expenditures
and it can be raised and lowered
throughout the process
as i said it is a statewide figure
so you don't assume an hhs specific
lapse but generally speaking
the governor's office will assign a
lapse target to each agency and expect
each agencies to manage to that figure
and
really the only other thing i would add
is that
the lapse requirement though contained
on our surplus statement is not
contained anywhere in state law so
there's an expectations expectation that
late agencies will manage to the lapse
but there's no legal aspect there's no
legal requirement that they do so so hhs
for example could theoretically spend
every dime of its appropriation but in
practice that just doesn't happen
so let me pull up our surplus statement
here just to give you an idea of what
i'm talking about
okay so i'm about to share
our surplus statement for the 2021
biennium
and you'll see here on lines
9 and 10 budget appropriations and
appropriation adjustments so that line
nine budget appropriations is everything
you would find in house bill one
line ten appropriation adjustments is
any spending that you would find either
in the trailer bill or any other bills
that the legislature has passed for that
year and then on line 11 you'll see less
general fund lapse estimate so for
fiscal 20 for example we assume that the
general fund lapse would be 56.7 million
and then in 21 that it would be 75.4
million uh in reality the actual figure
is going to be much higher than that i
think the the governor's surplus
statement assumes a lapse of 150.5
million dollars in fiscal 21.
but down here on line 12 total
appropriations you'll see that's simply
the net of everything that's been
appropriated either in the operating
budget or other bills
minus that statewide lapse estimate for
the year and that's how we arrive at net
appropriations
so i think that's a really quick
overview i don't know if you have any
questions about that
well that helps me a great deal and um
and what was really valuable was that i
that's true division three does not have
to assume any less so thank you for for
not bearing the lead in houston that is
one of your thesis statements i
appreciate it
so uh representative irf
okay i'm good
okay
do any of our uh other committee members
want to uh just comment in general about
what mr ripple just said
some of you have seen this a couple of
times
no i'm not really seeing any
um
well thank you
welcome
have you share the
portion of the governor's budget
related to
medicaid
okay
and then representative irf
in in background will you take a look at
um
the working document you put together so
that we can
yes sir
all right
now there are medicaid funds throughout
the hhs budget i wasn't sure what
account specifically you wanted to look
at so i just pulled up the biggest one
this is and this is the money i just i'm
just verifying this is the money that
that we match with the feds
and this is what
funds our
contracts with the managed care
organizations to provide actual hands-on
so
um
working assumption is that
uh we need to fully fund the general
fund's obligations to to fully receive
the federal funds
that that's that's my working theory
um
so
what
what what number are we looking at here
uh for the total general funds to fund
this is it the 75 no it's the 397 number
no it's the
now
representative
in in your
okay representative waller you have a
question
kevin i'm just wondering
what page is it in what page is it on
well you know what i'm saying
i see now that i'm looking up house bill
one rather than the governor's
recommended so let me just go back and
pull up the
it's the same accounting unit and the
same numbers of course but you aren't
able to see the comparison with 2021 so
right pull that up
account 7948 on page
there
i'll just highlight the general fun
totals for everybody to see
feels to me to be about
um
do we know why the governor recommended
that exact number because it's all all
the way down to the last dollar it's
exactly
you know
189 million 220
or 909
so
so that's a very precise number and that
implies
some very precise assumptions and so
uh
is is
ms rounds on
do you want to do you want to tell us
about what you can about that 189 number
or in the government on youtube
so
as far as the preciseness of it i i um
i would just speak briefly the athena
gagnon is the medicaid finance director
who works for me and works directly with
medicaid uh she has been doing medicaid
finance for
oh i don't know 20-ish years i would
guess at least kevin knows her well um
she
so she is very precise with her
budgeting so in addition to funding
the um
the managed care organization contracts
in this budget it also is the fee for
service
um as well as some other uh smaller
expenditures
so what i would do to explain the
changes here is to start at line 101
and what you're seeing
is a decrease
from
fiscal year 22
to
from fiscal year 21 of 731 million
to 706 million and the largest change
here is the establishment of the chip
account um and balancing what is in this
accounting unit versus what is in the
chip accounting unit uh in 1819
chip was within this accounting unit was
within 79.48 in 2021 we created the chip
account and so in 2223 we're trying to
balance what should be here and what
should be in the flip account we
actually have a fiscal item
that you'll see not on this week's
fiscal committee agenda but the next
fiscal committee agenda moving funds
from 7948 to the chip account
so that is uh the change in 101.
lines 535 and 563
are um
are transferred from the dcyf budget
they were previously in 2958.
if you remember during the presentations
both in dcyf and in medicaid we talked
about um how we're trying to put all of
the medicaid expenditures into the
medicaid budget for contracted medicaid
expenditures
or fee for service and so that
represents that change
and then when we go down to the overall
source of funds here
so there's a lot of moving parts when it
comes to the source of funds
the agency income i'm sorry the private
local funds on zero zero five are
related to the medicaid enhancement tax
so that can vary based on that um
the
general federal mix here in fiscal year
22 is different than 23 not only because
of the um
i'm sorry the mets is staying the same
there the difference there is the
federal funds and the reason for that is
during the governor's budget we adjusted
the federal funds
because it has been told to governors by
the federal government that the public
health emergency is likely to continue
through december so we made an
adjustment to the federal funds in
fiscal year 22
to reflect an additional urn of federal
uh due to that enhanced
fmap
that was a lot of words so i'm going to
stop
and see if there is
there's a lot a lot there so
representative waller you had your hand
up and you've taken it down was your
okay yes i'm fine
representative uh weiler
i noticed the difference
in federal funds general funds were
from 22 to 23.
the general funds went up but the
federal funds went down and then i heard
a talk about advanced f map that might
be the explanation for why the
we seem to be going up while they go
down so that that i guess that answered
that question is that correct correct mr
do you think um your explanation would
be significantly enhanced if we got ms
gagnon in here uh this afternoon
so the only i would say the the piece
that uh that athena could provide that i
don't know as well is all of the um
expenditures that make up 101 she could
tell you why that number is so precise
um that would be what she could probably
add for you
representative or you you have a
question
i do
can you explain why the
uh double o5 private local funds the met
why why is that budget much lower than
what much lower than actual and 20 and
somewhat lower than than this year's
adjusted authorized
uh that is because it the uh medicaid
enhancement tax is based on the previous
year and so fiscal year uh 22 would be
based on calendar year 21 um and the
hospitals are anticipated to have less
revenue in fiscal year 21 than what was
i mean yeah in calendar year 21 than
what was previously budgeted for fiscal
because the medicaid enhancement tax is
based on net patient service revenue
oh i don't have all right not not
relevant okay have a follow-up
representative
no
you're not moving oh there you go sorry
no i thought you could hear me not bad
so
uh i have a question for you
representative verv
yes sir
in the
worksheet
that you've worked so hard on
um
for the general funds
under 79.48
the governor's recommended is 189
229.
what number are you carrying in your
worksheet
that's comparable to that number
so the number that's currently there is
the fy 21 adjusted authorized which is
about 172 million dollars
and to get up to the governor's numbers
requires about
16.7 million dollars in fy 22
and about 34.5 million dollars in
fy 23 to get to the two-hole that takes
her the 207 million dollars he has
budgeted there
i that's a that's good information but
it's not the answer to my question
oh i'm sorry
that's right let me let me try it again
so
in in this particular
uh cell
of fy22 governors recommended
you have a comparable cell on your
worksheet
that used the fy 21 base
and then
projected a
working number
i'm asking you what your working number
was
that's comparable to the fy 22
it is the fy 21 adjusted authorized i
did not make up numbers in between i
either picked from
the
fy 22 governor
budget for a particular account
or i think from the fy 21 adjusted
authorized foreign account in some cases
after i'd picked one of the other
the other one had lower lines i might
have drawn a couple of those over but
that was very rare
okay so right now
the the the the working number that uh
your work document reflects is the 172
number
and it seems like we have a strong
argument to bring it up to fully fund
the governor's
request 189 229
and then in fy 23
to 207 132.
if if we were to do that
what what's that total
the the additional amount
so in year one it's 16.6 or 16.7 roughly
in year two 34.5
if you have those together you get
around what 51 million dollars over the
two-year biennium difference
so just to put that 51 million in
context
we had assumed i believe that we had
about a hundred million dollars that we
could add back from your working
document and this is about 51 million so
this is a this is a big
a big bill so
um but it seems like it's
it's an appropriate bill
i i i think we need to seriously
consider
uh
accepting the governor's recommended fy
22 and 23 numbers for
79.48
is there any is there any discussion
amongst the committee members on that
that point
representative wallner
well i
i just want to be sure that
what we're doing here is
um correct i i haven't even
actually to tell you the truth and i
haven't even found it in earth's
representative earth's document
um
so i mean it's
hard to find things in it and so i
i would like to
i'd like to have a minute to to look at
you're right the document that you're
looking at that i've been looking at is
out of order from the
the pdf document
um it's roughly a quarter of the way
through
um it's in
the
the medic
the division medicaid services title
which is in i think is included in that
document i'm looking not looking at it
right now
what's the second column from the left
well one thing about it is it's got 80
pages this document so it does have page
numbers so if we could at least get to
the page numbers i think it would be
i think i just got to the page number i
think if as we talk about this i think
if we can at least get to the correct
page numbers i don't see how anyone's
ever going to be able to follow what
we're doing here
if we can't even let me let me get there
so i can do that with you i was
i
apologize i would like to take the
tutorial on representative irf's
worksheet
uh offline
um because i do think
that we have in on this particular line
item
the clarity that is really important
which is
that if we accept the governor's
recommended budget
for 22 and 23 in account 79.48
then that
is going to
require us to apply
approximately 51 million
of the
approximately
100 million
that
that representative earth identified in
this process so so we just spent half
of the funds that we have available for
add backs
mr chairman
this uh page isn't it a summation of
several previous earlier pages and uh
earlier aus
that are included in this these figures
is that true mr ripple
these represent one accounting unit only
7948 medicaid care management it does
not reflect the other
i think that answers your question but
just to restate what i'm assuming we're
looking at is we're looking at the money
that becomes available for contracts to
so
representative nordgren i see you have
your hand up
thank you mr chair um i guess i have a
problem with offline discussions i think
all of us probably have the same
concerns that representative wallner has
so i'm not sure
what an offline discussion with her
might
help the rest of us
just
i i hear you yeah
remember
mr wait a second
representative nordgren i i i accept
your premise
um and i will schedule a chance for
uh representative irf to walk through
his working document
uh representative irf
tomorrow morning would you
be prepared please
to give us a tutorial on the uses and
limitations
of your working document i think it's
important to keep note
of what it is not it is not our proposal
it's just a
baseline for us to reference as we add
back
money to these lines
the short answer is yes but let me just
expound a little bit i would just not
prepare to give page numbers i am i can
do it now see at the same time i i do
not want to do that but that would just
help them see the numbers it's very easy
i do not want to do that now i want to
stay on the agenda and stay talking
about
the five
major funds that we have to discuss
we're now talking about one of them
we're talking about medicaid i i want to
make sure that we leave time to talk
about chip
uh i want to talk about tanf i want to
talk about mmis
and can i just tell them what page to
look at
sure
mr chairman so it's the bottom on page
mr chair
yes thank you
thank you i don't have a copy of that 80
page document and i'm not planning
to spend my printer ink on it so
it's a little difficult
to try to figure it out when we're
we don't have availability of it but we
could i guess we'll put it up on our
computers and hopefully we'll figure it
out
the representative i mean i represent
could kevin put it up
i can give him page numbers as we go yup
gonna rely on hope we're going to rely
on making sure again that this document
is available to you we talked this
morning about how it's going to be hung
on our public website once it's properly
watermarked
and tomorrow morning representative
earth is going to give us a tutorial on
and there's the account there at the
it's down thank you
all right
so
um
let's go back to the page you were
sharing mr ripple on
um
the governor's budget
uh yes let me just find where i
right
there we are
all right
so so what hopefully
we're taking from this discussion
is that
we probably ought to as a division
uh agree to fully fund the governor's
recommended
budget and
and if we do that that will
absorb
about 50 percent of the flexibility we
um
so we we will be talking about that uh
in future meetings but but i think i
think that's i want to put a stake in
the ground here for us to talk about
can we go to chip now can you do the
same thing for chip
yes and this is
easy because it's the next accounting
unit
so excuse me
so i see the general funds going up from
essentially 24 million
to essentially 38. that's
about just in just under 14 million and
and that it barely goes up in 23.
so so so ms rounds if you want to come
in and tell us things like why it goes
up so little in 23 and goes up so much
in 22 that would be great sure so uh as
i mentioned with the standard medicaid
account with 7948 this is the first time
or the second biennium
that the chip accounting unit has
existed and the first biennium that i
would say that we're trying to actually
level set this accounting unit where we
anticipate it will be
um
and we do as i mentioned have a fiscal
committee uh item going um for the april
agenda to transfer funds from 7948 to
this accounting unit 7051 which would
then change the adjusted authorized on
fiscal year 21.
um
this is what is being reflected as some
of the reduction in class line 101 uh
when we looked at 79.48
there was a reduction from 21
to 22 in the uh total expenditure and
that is essentially being moved to here
the fund mix um is a little different in
fiscal year 20
because of the enhanced f map and the
case will also be the same in fiscal
year 22
however on this account we have not made
an adjustment for fiscal year
i mean for fiscal year 21 we'll also
have some enhanced fm we have not made
an adjustment for fiscal year 22 in this
accounting unit because we are still um
trying to uh
process if you will the most recent uh
bill that passed at the federal level
and it seems like the enhanced fmap
might not apply to chip anymore and
we're trying to understand and process
uh that completely so we did not make
any changes
uh to fiscal year 22 regarding in an
enhanced fm
so the summary of that
is that if you were to make adjustments
based on some of the things you're
thinking about
would that
increase the 37 million requests you
think or would it decrease the 37
million request
so if the enhanced fmap does
uh apply to the chip kids it would
decrease the general funds
um the other thing i should have
mentioned on the standard medicaid
account and of course applies to
anywhere that we're making a medicaid
payment is the 3.1 rate increase that
happened um 1-1 of 21
so anywhere in fiscal year 21 would only
represent half a year of that rate
increase
okay i i i think you may have said it
different than i was expecting to hear
it
i think what you were saying is that
that in fy 22 for the 37.7 million
you assumed the enhanced f map
and that if you don't get the enhanced f
map
then we have to come back and adjust
this number if we have less enhanced
fmap it seems to me like the general
fund amount would have to go up
i'm sorry no we we did not include any
enhanced death map in 22 or 23
in this accounting unit because we're
not sure if it will change so it
if we do end up getting the enhanced
fmap we knew would need less general
funds here but we don't have clarity yet
as to whether we will
appreciate that uh representative weiler
do you have a question sir
i'm curious as to why we go up more than
50 from 21 to 22.
so fiscal year 21 20 and 21 was the
first biennium that we had this
accounting unit and so we weren't
entirely sure how
at what level to budget it uh so fiscal
year 21 is under budget it's it's not
enough money and we have a fiscal
committee item to adjust that to be
higher
yes sir
i thought we'd had
ships uh this children's health
insurance program for for a decade
we did and uh it used to be that these
uh
these expenditures were just part of
7948.
uh if you remember the single audit from
2018 there was a finding on the
department about our medicaid revenues
not being transparent enough and so we
created several accounting units um
including this one to break out what was
thank you
so to
visualize
the answer to representative weiler can
can we scroll back up mr ripple to uh
medicaid where we see fy22 dropping to
the 706 number or whatever i think it's
a little further up
so so
i think on line 101 representative
weiler
you'll you'll you'll see that uh in 20
um
20 and 21
it was basically higher than it's going
to be in 22 on this line item and that's
because in part chip got moved
and money money came out of this and got
added to the chip line
is it is that right ms rounds yes
doesn't look like the same amount
it wouldn't be because of that 3.1 rate
increase
that's that's going to affect it
officer
thank you
all right um
let's go back to the chip line where we
okay
so
miss rounds i'm i'm so sorry let's let's
just for for for people uh out in the
audience and for me as well
tell me again exactly
who is eligible for the chip program and
and
and how that's used to purchase
direct health
care
so
i'm just looking through the attendees
to see if henry was on or
um i i can't answer that
and not
okay
but he needed its children and they are
part this these payments would also go
to the mcos it's all part of the mco
contract
okay i thought this might be part of a
fee for service
section of what we spend money on
because it's more of an insurance
product
no they they are part of the mcos
okay
a different uh eligibility group if you
will
okay
so
uh
so what i'm thinking is as we look at
we probably
are are
wanting to fully fund the governor's
recommended budget
because i think this is money
that that ends up setting up
direct health care
and and to me that's um a priority
so
um
and i'm now did you or can you can you
keep that highlighted uh mr ripple
because i lose sight of it
it looks like um that's going to
absorb
about 27 to 28 million
of
the
funds that we have available for add
back
do you
do you agree with that representative if
we if we add this if we add
to your work document fy 22 general
funds for 70 51 and 23
that that that that takes another 27 28
million doesn't it
correct and that's on page 18
of the pdf
if we take 50 and 28
we're now at 78
million of the approximately 100 million
that we
have overall
that right now based on the ways and
means estimate that we can add back
so we're down to about 22 million or so
and in this one
we give ourselves a little bit of a
problem
in that we're expecting those revenue
flows to come in
um greater in 23 than 22 and and we're
we're using the same number in both
years
i think we were trying to keep a
one-third two-thirds
rule but this would violate that
representative nordgren do you have a
comment or a question yeah i'm sorry
this is probably
not the right place to ask it but you
did mention
the ways and means committee and i was
just wondering what the status was of
the conversations
that
a representative weiler has been having
with uh representative major in ways and
means are they planning to revisit their
numbers
i
the short answer to that is yes and i'll
let representative weiler provide a
longer answer if he if he cares to
but at this point in this exercise
we have not been told anything other
than the ways and means estimate that
the house voted on that we're still
using that for our planning
so if we are are lucky enough for ways
and means to come back and give us more
money
this exercise we're going through right
now is still useful and relevant
so representative weiler do you want to
talk about where you're at with ways and
means sir
that's that's really soon i didn't think
we'd hear until tuesday the 23rd so i
like a friday answer better
well i'm not sure that's that was a kind
of a preliminary thing
did representative
yes so when i was looking at uh
representative erf's documents
um
it looked like
he had reduced the governor's budget by
159 million
no
no no no no
well it's 50 159 million less
the governor's budget is uh 159 million
more
than
the fy 21 adjusted base and
and he uses a different revenue
estimation process and so he had
greater amounts of revenues to use in
his separate distinguishable independent
effort
we are using the new hampshire house
process
of of of taking a look at our current
budget
taking a look at the ways and means
estimates
and determining how much that weighs and
means estimate how much money that gives
us
to enhance the fy 21 base
we're using different techniques
than the governor because he has more
flexibility on revenue estimates than we
do
okay i i understand that part but i'm
just trying to i'm just trying to figure
out so you're saying you're
to your base you're adding back 100
million
that's your goal
yes ma'am i think the ways and that's
trying to reach where where
where you're going so that means it's
about 59 million
that
is reduced
no
if you add that
no no that 59 million is is an
irrelevant useless number to us
we we have a process where we must use
the ways and means revenue estimate
gives us a delta
between the ways and means estimate as
is voted on by the new hampshire house
between that revenue estimate and the
money's being
spent in the fy21 budget
what we are doing is we're using our own
independent process to build from an
fy21 base to allocate the funds that are
available as a result of the ways and
means revenue estimate
it's it's parallel but it's completely
separate from
the governor's
process
well i'm just trying to get to i'm i'm
just trying to get a simple number
of i'm just trying to get to a point
where
i understand how much either you're
adding back and it looked like it looked
like you were 159 million
under
the governor's budget
the governor estimated 159 million over
the fy 21 base that's what 159
represents and from your base you're
trying to add back
100 million
i'm trying to stay within the ways and
means revenue estimate and that allows
us 100 million at this point right okay
we're on the same we're on the same
track
every single one of us wants the ways
and means estimate on friday to be
greater so that there's more than 100
million
okay so
there's 59 million
as of today using the ways and means
estimates
doing 100 there's 59 million
that's still out there
that the governor's budget
is higher
than if we if we did add back the
hundred
i would i would say it differently as
you wouldn't be surprised i would say
that
the revenue estimation
techniques
used by others and not us
the governor's revenue estimation
technique and the ways and means revenue
estimation technique
disagree with each other and
to the tune of about 59 million dollars
thank you
and and that we have no control over
that we we are downstream
from the people who do the revenue
estimate and so we we can only
spend what we've got and what we've got
is
about 100 million over the fy21 base and
right yeah
i i think we're on the same i think
we're at the same place so if
just as an example ways and means came
in on friday
and had an additional 10 million dollars
yeah then we would
again the 49 million would be irrelevant
we would have an additional 10 million
to put on to the fy 21 base
so you'll note
that i'm fastidiously avoiding
the term cut
because we're not cutting anything
we we are adding we're using our
legislatively approved process to add
money back we're not cutting anything
so um that's my position i'm sticking to
it
so representative waller do you do you
want no
that's fine i
just think it's
sometimes amusing okay thank you
i i try sometimes to be amusing i i hope
we're in sync
so
um okay
so where were we when we we last looked
at chip
if we went with the governor's numbers
we would have consumed about 78 million
of the 100 million that ways and means
said we had
so so we got another 22 million
that we could potentially add back on
other lines
are there are there any comments or
questions about where we are because
because i think we're about to go look
okay so i i would like us all to be
thinking through
the possibility that we're division
three's recommendation for line 7051
representative walnut your hand is up is
that a
do you have another question
yes i do i i wondered if karen was still
on
i mean i know that there is medicaid in
a number of other spots in this budget
and how does accepting
some lines without other lines
affect all of that
have we hit all of the uh
medicaid lines in the budget
so the other large medicaid
provider type payments are in
um
developmental disabilities and long-term
supports and services and
uh well actually it's all in long-term
supports and services it's long-term
care which is mostly a county match
the developmental disabilities accounts
so so let's um
let's let's let's react here on the fly
i get uh miss ripple if you would just
think about how you would get us to the
development
disabilities uh line
representative wallner your hand is
still up is that a follow-up no i no i
just wanted to i just want to be sure
we've seen all of the medicaid lines
i think that's a great question and i i
share your concern and i appreciate miss
round's answer
um and and i will adapt to it
thank you mr chair i would like to ask
the surrounds
on the a m uh report it's they
pointed out how
the
hhs was not achieving the maximum amount
of medicaid because of the way you filed
has there been any changes in the way
you file and what are they reflected in
the 2223
budget
i'm not sure if i know
exactly which finding you're referring
to there there is a finding about 4e
that we're not claiming enough for e um
that is not fully reflected in the
budget because we have not been able to
implement all of the changes that need
to happen to do that
um
there was also some discussion about i
think the
medicaid reports that we file and having
some technology difficulties related to
mmis and again the the funds to
upgrade mmis are in the capital budget
um so that would probably likely be
thank you is there a plan to adopt some
of their recommendations
yes yes and um i know that the hb2 part
of that is coming up on friday and i
will have folks from a m available to uh
speak to their findings as well
um
but we are planning on implementing i
believe um
almost all of them and and really all of
them in time uh there's a couple that uh
you can't take on simultaneously so it
will come later in the process hopefully
but there's four or five six that were
that we're starting work on right now
okay uh i'm not seeing any other hands
up um
let's let's
if you're ready to take us to the uh
the activity code for the
developmentally disabled
yeah karen do you have that accounting
unit off the top of your head because i
let's take a let's take a five minute
bio break here and and we'll come back
and we'll we'll go to developmentally
disabled and then we'll go to long-term
care supports and then we'll try to hit
tanf
appendix a that's probably the easiest
thing to work from
okay
do you want me to resend it over to you
if you don't mind no i don't mind
oops
[Music]
and that is a little easier because it
so
it's
agency 93
so long-term supports and services is
two different agencies so it starts
on page 11 32.
okay thank you you're welcome i'm just
going
when you find a camera just let me know
the account number
yep sure
professional care
should be called developmental services
oh no wrong stuff odd because i thought
okay got it do you happen to know what
the other one is going to be the um
long-term
care once you mentioned
i
i'm not sure what that one would be okay
okay we'll get there
i know that
so later we'll be looking at tanf and i
know that's 6146.
yeah attend if i can find you i can
it's when they make up these names that
aren't in this spreadsheet i can't find
and just so you know it's page
10 has the oh no that's not it either
700.
i still gotta find out that's there's
two there's too many 7100s
i think that's kind of where he's
page 64 if we get to that point
so i'm i'm personally ready to get going
again um
i'm here i think karen was just taking a
quick break she'll be right back
it's not that she couldn't catch up
quickly i just
you want to go ahead and share your
document them though on the
shore
hey keith
yes sir
um on your on your worksheet
would you just tell me
which of the numbers you put into your
worksheet did you put in
the 1
64 5 number from the adjusted authorized
i put in the
160.1
since that's a lower number than the
164.
and i just at this point
23 was the same as 22.
so the only difference here in other
words is would be the 15 million
and
23.
does that make sense
do we have an enhanced f map for that
23.
i don't think there would be enhanced f
map in 23 and if i heard ms rounds right
we're not assuming any enhanced f map in
22 even even though we may get it and it
might look like a windfall when it
happens she didn't use the term windfall
though
she did assume it in
the large the very with a really large
medicaid account because that one
they are allowing he's back now hi hi
miss rounds hello
i think uh representative weiler just
wants to sync up on you with you on on
enhanced fmap and how it affects the
planning assumptions for 22 and 23.
okay
um so
the only
accounting unit that we made an
adjustment for the enhanced fmap for 22
only uh was 79.48
we are hearing that the enhanced fmap is
likely to go through until december 31st
it is dependent on
when the public health emergency ends at
the federal level
so uh we have received indications that
it will continue through the end of the
calendar year so we made the adjustment
in 79.48
we have not made it anywhere else
including this accounting unit
so if we get okay i want i just want to
make sure again i'm understanding what
you're telling us i i think
what we're saying is that for
line
um
seven one zero zero
the
160.1 million that's in fy22
assumes a traditional match it does not
assume the enhanced depth map
but that if
but that if we get the enhanced f map
it would it would look and i'm going to
use the word windfall a lot of budget
people don't like the term but i i think
i think it's going to be
surplus money that we didn't count on
and therefore it looks like a windfall
and it's also possible that we're going
to get more guidance from the feds
between now
and
say the committee at conference
and so before the final budget gets
locked in
maybe we'll have a different better
grounded estimate for this account yes
we would definitely
try to make any adjustments we can
before committing a conference um based
on the guidance at that time
but so for now we're assuming no
enhanced map
correct
okay so
uh for the
developmental developmentally disabled
services
i would like on line 7100
i would
like us to discuss
the idea that we should accept the
governor's recommended budget
and and to get to that conversation why
don't we start out
uh mr ripple or ms ms rounds off either
of you
on explaining the difference between
uh the fy 21 one
64.5
and the 160.1 because it goes down in
the first year of the governor's budget
sure i can i can do that uh
the this accounting unit was established
to be a revolving account um in
fiscal year 2021. um this to the
discussion earlier with representative
irf doesn't show revolving funds because
it is funded with the general fund
and with the federal match
because of it now being a revolving
account the fiscal year
22 budget
has been requested assuming that we will
have about a 38 million dollar carry
forward
uh in total funds from 21 into 22.
so the reality is that budget is
actually
um
you know what would be available in
fiscal year 21 is more like
350 million um and of course
being anticipated it is anticipated that
some of those funds would not get used
in 22 and would carry forward to 23. um
so that is why you're seeing a reduction
there it's not
actually a
reduction in what's available to be
spent but it is a reduction in what is
being requested for general funds in 22.
so do you do you know if the department
uh
i mean obviously they work for the
governor but uh the does does the
department agree on the three lines that
we've discussed so far with the
governor's budget number
so our request was a little bit higher
than the governor's request than the
governor's budget i'm sorry uh
but we believe that the governor's
so
so are there questions or comments about
uh
the 7100 line i i think
if we were to accept the governor's
budget what what that would mean in
terms of
our ability to use the ways and means
estimate that would mean
that
fy22
is what
work document assumes fy23
would add
15 million
so
if you take the 78
plus the 15
we're now
uh at about 93 million
of the 100
that we had
have available to to add back into
the fy21 base
so so we're at 93 million at this point
i think
are there are
are there any questions i i happen to
think that this is a line that we would
i'm not i'm not seeing any uh questions
here so let's go to
the long-term care support line
before we do that there are actually two
other accounting units associated with
um
that are
also associated with developmental
services
which is
acquired brain disorder which is 7016
and
revolving accounts
yeah so these um
the governor's budget
represents a decrease in what's in fy 21
but because it's a revolving account you
think you have the resources to to do
what's needed for 7016 over the coming
correct so that's why you see a decrease
in general funds from fiscal year 21 in
both years
but i believe um
from what i've been explained of
representative or spreadsheet it may be
that the 22 total appropriation would be
represented in both 22 and 23.
his working document in this case i
believe assumes the governor's budget
numbers could you confirm that
representative yes yes sir that is
correct
okay so we could we could ex we could
on 7016 accept the governor's budget and
it would no would not have an impact
on the amount of money we have available
for add-backs no it actually would
increase because in the second year it's
14 million in the governor's budget so
that would be three million dollars
higher than the
and the eleven oh
okay so there's a
there's a a 2.6 million dollar
bill here
is that right
i i can't do mental math very well well
i was saying three but 2.6 is probably
right yes it's in that range
so
let's go ahead and keep it free just to
keep it simple so
if we were at
93 we're now at about 96.
um so so let's
so this looks like
from
your work document
the only uh
effect of the of accepting the
governor's budget
is that the
4.4 in fy 23
represents about a 700 000
increase from your work document
correct
so we were at 96 let's say we're at
out of 100.
so is there any discussion around
accepting or modifying the governor's
proposal on this line item we talked
about
is this uh is this this is 7110 we
talked about 7100 7016.
so far all three of them
the the working conversation is around
accepting the governor's budget proposal
on these lines
does any of the committee want to
all right
well now let's go to long-term care
supports
so what accounts specifically i'm sorry
what account do you mean by long-term
supports
counting cap discussion
it is
yes yeah
i want to postpone that to this
afternoon anyways
is there what well what else
that that's it that's
everything else is just
not just it's medicaid administration
not payments to providers so that's um
so
um
i think we're ready to go look at tanf
uh representative wallner do you have a
question could we just take a look at
the medicaid administration lines
how we how that is
if if that's a lot lower
than the governor's
budget
i'd have to wonder how they're going to
be able to
do all this work okay
so
just
now medicaid administration we earn all
across the department it's not just in
one area
um
but there is
the medicaid administration accounting
unit which is just related to
administering the standard medicaid
account which is 7937
it's on page 990.
9.90
so ms rounds um
while uh representative uh
walnut looks at that and gets ready to
ask you questions
um
i
based on what i've been thinking i would
like to see
authorized personnel
do you happen to know how many personnel
permanent authorized there were for 19
in this line
so
it's going to be very difficult to
compare
the adjusted authorized numbers
by accounting unit for fiscal year 19
because we moved a lot of positions in
20 and 21 to be in the right place
so
it would be very difficult to do by
accounting unit
so you know in general what i'm what i'm
thinking about proposing
is for us to
uh
use all of the 2019
uh authorized permanent positions
and not the 21
and not the proposal in 23.
so
i don't know how to have that
conversation because that that sounds
like it would be a very complicated
hard thing to do but
but i
i would like to have
go ahead
i so i
i mean i i really can't have that
conversation without telling you all of
the potential consequences right like
we're not going to have as many beds at
new hampshire hospital available
our case loads per caseworker and dcyf
would go up uh you know i'm not going to
file reports timely with the federal
government uh we're not going to get con
every contract that goes to gnc will
probably be retroactive and
you know like there are serious
consequences for going to that level
so can i tell you my simple perhaps
overly naive assumption though sure
and and why i didn't think it was a
crazy idea to begin with and that is
that
whenever we heard the department talking
they had vacancy rates
and um
and when i looked at the
in general and i wasn't looking line by
line but in sort of a top down big
picture view
it appeared that the actual number of
personnel
employed in the permanent classified
line
was lower
than the fy 19
personal personnel a permanent
authorized
and and and that gap
would theoretically provide an
opportunity to continue to hire
and continue to
become how help the department become
more effective
that that rolling back to 19 didn't
actually represent a cut in employees
because there was still room between
that number and the vacancy number
now now
so we should schedule it and have a have
a discussion about that i don't i don't
want to do anything stupid you know but
but i do want to talk through that
concept
okay yeah and i think it's a little
difficult uh
right now because we've just come off of
a year-long hiring freeze
during that year which we hired maybe 30
people um which when you're considering
a 3 000 employee department it is
it's a little difficult to think that we
could stay at the staffing levels we're
at right now
yes ma'am i i know that's why we should
have that conversation and
we'll schedule it
okay all right so representative
i'm just looking at the uh medicaid
administration
lines um
i i assume you what what what number is
on the um
representative earth's document
i i would say it's probably the fy 21
number of
5 million okay so that's what i was
thinking so it looks like we're about
three million dollars
short in each year of general funds
yeah so that would be a fresh six
million uh request and given our last
number i think
uh was 97 million
that would make us at 103.
so representative er if you want to
correct us or
clarify no
i just want to point out that so far
what we've been increasing is the
amounts like the 3.1 increase and all
that not necessarily increasing the
workload which i think is what would be
in this account i'm not mistaken
i think your point is that the
administration line ought to be able to
absorb the work because we're increasing
the the
dollars moving but not necessarily the
workload underneath it
is that what you
i want you i just want to understand
representative first
yes sir i'm sorry yes
can i see representative irv spreadsheet
on the screen yeah
what is this accounting unit um
you turn on the medicaid services one
yeah four seven zero zero
uh
okay
it seems like there's something else
going on here because we're we're
collecting a lot more federal money on
this line
than ever before so i
would like to
hear what an explanation of that is too
18 19 kevin
okay
so looking at like class 10
so going a little bit back to the
personnel discussion we're just having
22 and 23 are budgeted
to include things like um step increases
which are required by the union contract
and then of course there's an extra pay
period in 23.
so by level funding it to 21 on the
salary class line you have essentially
cut positions
and if that's what's happened all
throughout this document you've already
cut positions all throughout the
document
because we won't be able to hire all the
positions because we'll have to absorb
any step increases in employees pay as
well as that extra pay period in 23.
you don't happen to know what your
vacancies are in this line item though
that would be
that would be a level of
detail that no person could carry around
in their head i don't but i i guess i'm
just saying if that's what you've done
in every personnel section there are
sections where
they're it's fully staffed and so we
would
we would need to transfer funds around
the department to not lay people off
um
and then do not you want to know what my
real hope is ms
okay so here's my real hope
that division three
pass
passes a really good conceptual budget
that um
that the senate will will use as a
reference point
and that the department will have a
little bit more time to look at and and
be able to offer some good fine-tuning
uh recommendations to the senate
and that and that after the senate works
on it we still have a few months before
the committee conference locks
everything down
and so i i'm not my goal and maybe i'm
wrong but my goal is not to pass a
perfect budget
but a really good one that communicates
clearly a conceptual framework of what
we're trying to do
knowing that
it's
whatever we do
is going to get amended twice and and
that we've got a couple months to get
smarter and to make those amendments and
fine-tuning not not us our division
but the senate and the committee
conference
so i kind of trust the process that
comes after us
to to clean up some of the details
okay
at the same time
i don't want to
hand off
a mess
so so the more so we're going to talk
about the personnel issue and and if my
concept
doesn't really work
i'll change it
okay no and i appreciate that i'm just
trying to give you real-time feedback on
what i'm seeing
um in this document and i would have
some of the same concerns with the
benefits line we we don't have any
control over what the benefits cost and
if people have changed plans and all
that type of stuff that that certainly
in fact impacts the budget line
the other thing i would
go ahead
no no i i
it was rude so i'm sorry
the other thing i was just going to
mention is that class lines 40 41 and 42
are all 100
non-general funds
so
any changes you've made to those three
class lines would not impact the general
funds in this accounting unit
are in any accounting unit
that 40 41 and 42 or
are always 100 federal or 100 other or
some mix of federal and other there are
never general funds in those three class
lines
and that's the other thing too when it
comes to some of these class lines there
are times where the fund mix is
different than just dividing um
by the numbers at the bottom some class
lines may have a different fund mix than
others especially when it comes to the
so i think that's why most budget people
really like to have the ability to
increase funding because they don't have
to worry about the details of having
scarcity
and and we're in a situation where we
have to manage scarcity and i don't know
how
you know in the in the few weeks
even if even if i'd been looking at this
budget for you know 10 years i don't
know how in a few weeks
i would know all the fine-tuning issues
around scarcity
so represent representative nordgren uh
you have your hand up ma'am
yes
yes um i guess
uh karen brings up
concerns that we're all having who've
been doing people who've been doing this
for 20 30 years that this is a new way
of doing it and i think it's really
important for her to point out
the ramifications of this different
process so i would hope we could
continue
to go through the various line items
that she
thinks uh we're taking a risk
in um how we're
doing the process thank you
i i agree with you completely
and i i am yeah i'm i'm con my biggest
concern is the amount of of work that
it's not inconceivable that
i would have to do a department-wide
transfer like
by month four of the first year of the
fiscal year if what i'm seeing here is
is true throughout the other class line
so that's my concern
um
i think
that
i don't know i don't i don't know
exactly what to say but
certainly if you have
areas that um
that you would like to see the funding
change because you have
you know a different
uh mission or you know a different way
that you think we should do it i i can
help a lot and and giving you
information to help you understand
what
changing different funding areas are but
it's really hard when it when it's every
class line like this because we've made
very specific decisions on how to reduce
and increase things
to
to try to come to a
you know a fair budget so
that's just my immediate reaction having
not spent a lot of time looking at this
document
okay so to be fair with you what so what
my concern is is i look at the the
personnel growth over the last
the prior budget the current budget the
proposed budget
we're growing and and realizing that the
pandemic cost of hiring freeze
you know midway through the
current year it's created a big vacancy
number
so
my concern is that with that that growth
rate and the fact that we had
the pandemic induced
vacancy rate
if we accept the personnel growth as it
is
we're asking the taxpayers of new
hampshire
to fund government at a rate faster than
the economy is growing
and i that is not a sustainable position
we can't do that
and every time we hire
a permanent classified employee
we end up
with
a long-term tail that is also
unsustainable we already have huge
problems with our pension funds so every
person we put onto the
pension fund we're just aggravating that
problem to
another level
so
i think i think what
i'm trying to do and maybe others are
trying to do with this budget
is to figure out
how to
dramatically rein in the rate of growth
and personnel
because it's not sustainable
but do it in a way
in which we protect
the current employees we don't want to
screw with their step increases their
promotions we don't want to we don't
want to stop uh vital hiring
but
but at the same time we have to ask
management
that in the context of an economy that
just got sucker punched and
can we please
tighten our belt
the way
businesses have had to tighten their
belt
there are no businesses that i know of
that are growing their personnel numbers
at this rate
and and i i have a hard time being part
of a process that
allows
what
many people from the business world
would consider to be
an out-of-control personnel growth rate
so so i'm trying to figure out how to
balance this this this this macro
concern
with the reality of the department
because i don't want to break the
department
and fully stating that i i don't support
reducing any of our positions i i want
to make that really clear but if you
were
looking to
um
to reduce the number of positions that
and reduce the cost so it's about a
hundred positions
equals five million dollars in general
funds
now some people would want to break that
down as one position as fifty thousand
dollars but
to really get to the five million it
takes a hundred different positions
right because
cost allocation every position is a
little bit different so i i wouldn't
want to break that down to 50 000 per
position but it's about 100 positions is
5 million dollars in general funds so if
you were looking to
um
to reduce the number of positions in the
department by 100 positions i'm just
using that as an example you could put a
provision in hb2 that says the
department's personnel line personnel
lines i should say because they could be
salary or benefits
shall be reduced by 5 million dollars
during the biennium or
it would 100 positions would be 10
million for the biennium it's 5 million
a year
um
so you could do something like that
which would then allow us the
flexibility to
manage within
a cost
and not have as many positions filled at
any one time
that would also save the lba from having
to go in and key a lot of lines
of information so uh mr ripple can you
scroll down oh no that's right already
there so it's just really faint um on
permanent unclassified
is is 28 um
and i guess that's on um
are we looking at representative earth's
worksheet
yes
okay
so
i would also like to
be able to cause some of these lines to
be keyed so that they get reduced
so that we maintain
a baseline somewhere
there's got to be a baseline
whether it's 19 or 21 i you know i like
i said my goal isn't to break things but
my goal is to represent the taxpayers
interests
in having the management of department
of health and human services
accept the business realities of the
underlying economy that pays the bills
and we need to we we can't allow
personnel growth at this rate it just
could you could force that in the hb2
language and say that we must reduce the
class lines in the appropriation
all right so then when you come back for
24 25 those reductions would be
represented in the class lines we would
go through the we would go through and
tell department of administrative
services where to make reductions
because a lot can happen between now and
june too which is the other thing that
makes me a little nervous about reducing
class lines in particular areas that the
decision we might say today well if
you're telling us we have to unfund this
i would do it here might be a little
different four months from now
that's an excellent point
so if if you wouldn't mind
some language around that
and sharing it with us
then i think
you would be fulfilling the role of
helping me so i don't
for us so that we don't break the
department
but but that we do we do something to
put some personnel controls in place
i don't think anyone
view you as a trader for doing that
because you're on the record of saying
you don't support any of these cuts
and i i would um i'll work with kevin on
that and i would just say that it won't
break the department from a financial
management point of view but the
commissioner would absolutely say that
it would break the department from being
able to run it effectively
i understand i never ran into a
subordinate commander who didn't think
they needed more people to do something
so
um so rep representative walner i think
yeah thank you so just to go back to
this
area
so i i'm looking at this and um i have a
note to myself here
that
um class
the transfer to other state agencies
here is a transfer to new hampshire
hospital
and first i assume that new hampshire
hospital has earned
this amount of medicaid
funding
and yet because the way the document is
you is
designed
we use a
much less
um line to fund them i mean it goes from
actually
34 million in the governor's budget and
then 36 in the in the 23
down to 20 to new hampshire hospital i
mean what
what does that what kind of a
what kind of an error is that going to
that is a class line that is 100 federal
funds i did submit a change request to
reduce it a little bit because it is
it is a little bit too high to match to
what new hampshire hospital budgeted
but
we if that line was reduced below where
it needed to be i would have to go to
fiscal committee and accept the
additional federal funds to transfer to
okay so
that's outside of what we're working on
today i don't think we're messing with
federal funds
but all of this i mean to me in my mind
all of this
it's because when you get down to the
bottom and you you're looking the
federal funds are going to drop
to 28 million
when the
general funds dropped to 5 million in 22
and then
let's bring representative irf in here
because he's been he's been working on
these lines too and i'd be interested in
what what he has to say about it
thank you
a lot of this discussion is moot
for the following reasons
i've been waiting karen to speak
directly with you
i'm well aware
of these issues in fact i've gone
through
the document you provided us that shows
line by line general fund federal fund
kind of breakdowns and in some cases
i've actually applied them
the suggestion you just made regarding
the
wages if you tell me what class lines
they are in other words it's not
obviously it's not just 10 and 12 but
the the
the benefits and all that kind of thing
i can go through and make all those
adjustments and then we'll know exactly
what the total is the total differential
is
and then we could say yes um we need to
reduce 50 positions 100 positions
whatever the number may be
with regard to the point that um
representative walling just brought up
again that's something else that would
automatically change this was never
intended to be
a budget it's not a budget
it's a it's it's a place where we're
going to where it was easy for me to add
things back in and all the things that
we've talked about this morning that
representative
excuse me mr chairman has brought up
have been added back in so we can see
those totals and i can do that
progressively when you have time karen i
would love to uh
representative i mean uh miss rounds um
i would love to start with you and again
because i can make these kinds of
so probably we could go back to the uh
the governor's budget instead of
representative erf's uh working document
thank you
um so uh
representative weiler you've had your
hand up for quite a while sir
yes thank you um
i don't remember before seeing in all
these budgets all this additional fringe
benefits now the
the benefits are already a seat
getting close to 60 70 percent of the of
the wages and if this is this just an
excuse to
hide the fact they might be at 80
percent what are additional fringe
benefits we never used to see them in
the budget now i see it every line thank
you
you want to address that ms rounds kevin
could you bring over michelle carraway
maybe to explain it from das sure you
know let's let's do it this way it's
it's 2 11.
um
we're we're kind of at a good spot to
break for lunch
so so let's do that at one o'clock if
you wouldn't mind
uh representative walter do you have a
question or comment before we go
okay
yes
so um because i sense that that may be a
longer conversation and a good one let's
let's uh use it to start the uh at one
o'clock
so i are with you representative weiler
sir
okay
all right so um
is there anything that you need to say
or want to say here ms rounds
before we lose our train of thought is
there something that you've got on the
tip of your tongue
i don't i don't think so i i
i guess i would say to uh representative
ruff about your request to sit down i i
we would definitely need to schedule
time and i would need to have probably
all of my finance directors part of that
meeting because there are things in
every accounting unit that are really
specific that i don't necessarily know
so
so if if if you
um could work on some language how long
would it take you to come up with some
hp2 language that might
get most of what i'm looking for which
is some sort of a personnel ceiling
uh that's lower than what's
projected
i don't i don't think that would take
long i defer to kevin but i don't think
it'll take long
we should be able to get you something
by the end of the day today
let's let's think that we're going to
talk about it tomorrow then please okay
representative earth your hand is up
it's 2 13. you got 120 seconds this will
be very quick
miss rounds i understand that if you
could i know you could quickly give me
the basic class lines if you just tell
me what those are i can get going i
realize that's not the full answer that
would okay that's part way there uh 10
12 17 18 19
okay and does the
does the gff
match vary from line to from person to
from account to account
yes okay right yes
i use the 5 million per 100 positions as
an across the department average
i'm just doing it okay thank you very
much okay so um if you would put up a
sign mr ripple that will be back at one
o'clock and turn off the recording uh
then that would be great
i will